welcome back to just one project has
announced its latest giving campaign
Skip One and give one and here to tell
us what it's all about is the just one
project founder and CEO Brooke neubauer
Brooke thank you so much for being here
thank you so much for having me so I
have known you for a while and I just
have to say congratulations on
everything that the just one project is
doing in the community you've grown so
much for people who don't know tell us a
little bit about the just one project uh
the just one project we are Nevada's
largest mobile food pantry our mission
is to connect the community Through
volunteerism while creating access to
groceries and wraparound services and
other resources that the community might
need support with and you've been
feeding thousands of people per month
right your numbers just keep going and
growing we are extremely lucky that the
community trusts us in their time of
need we touch about 20 000 lives every
single month and that is just through
client served we also average over 500
volunteers monthly to pull off all of
our our program so we are definitely
volunteer driven well that is incredible
that you've built this community to help
give back and support our community here
in Vegas so let's talk about this new
campaign skip one give one what does
that mean skip one give one to just one
it's really just a campaign to inspire
people to pay forward kindness whether
you want to skip a five dollar coffee or
a night out and donate it to the just
one project so it can help us provide
meals for families home delivered meals
to seniors that are stuck at home so all
across our programs and throughout the
year you're doing so much but I'm sure
during this period of time with the
holidays you're amping up things even
more you guys have a lot of different
community events and projects coming up
can you tell us a little bit about those
yeah there's so many amazing ways to get
involved whether it's volunteering at
our fresh farmers markets we have a
no-cost community grocery store with
wraparound Services we're always looking
for volunteers we have an amazing youth
program
um and my favorite is Sam's Workshop of
course one of my favorite things about
the just one project is that 96 of every
96 cents of every dollar race goes
straight into programs which is amazing
so we're really proud of that well
Brooke thank you for everything that
you're doing in the community and I'm
really excited about this new campaign I
think it's going to help feed a lot of
families and if people want to get
involved where should they go for
information well we're big on social
find us on all social media outlets and
of course our website and Google us
we're there we're everywhere we'll find
you congratulations thank you again for
supporting our community and uh we'll
we'll have to have you back in talk
about the Santa's workshop and all the
fun stuff you have going on thank you so
much thank you all right time to check